tehom asks can you explain langlin's
program and does it have any connection
to physics
no yes um langland's program
if you had to say it in one sentence it
would say that
automorphic forms on groups have
something to do with
representations of galway groups which
sounds like this
obscure technical stuff
but um rather amazingly an awful lot of
problems in mathematics
turn out if you go very deep into them
to to be related to the langlens
program for example um the classic
example of this is wireless proof of
firma's last theorem was was essentially
using this
idea doesn't have anything to do with
physics
well some of the more recent work on
geometric language is using ideas from
quantum field theory
so i can give you a definite maybe on
that one
um there are certainly some ideas that
turn off in both langman's program and
physics whether or not there's any more
direct connection
i don't know but it wouldn't surprise me
langley's program seems to
it seems to be one of these things that
turns up almost everywhere if you go
really deeply into something
and you mentioned that you're extremely
interested in learning more about it
i've been so for decades and there's
there's just so much to learn
i mean um
i mean that langland's program seems to
be the ultimate black hole for what you
need to learn in order to understand it
like there are there are several very
deep subjects like representation theory
and algebraic geometry which are
themselves notorious for how
how much you have to learn to get into
them and langlen's program sort of
sub-sums all of these you need to know
algebraic geometry and representation
theory
and a lot of hard analysis so it's more
or less
it's almost like it's every hard area of
mathematics all combined into one